Getting comfortable with ripping out rows
of knitting is essential for every machine
knitter.
Has this ever happened to you?
You've found that you've knit too many
rows, or maybe you forgot an increase or a
decrease, or even worse, you look down
and there's a big 'ol knot or slub a yarn
right in the middle of your knitting.
Well, you'll need to rip back a few rows.
In this tutorial we'll talk
about a quick way of ripping.
Now this technique works best with
a bit of weight on the knitting.
Even if you don't normally knit with
weights, add some before beginning.
First remove your yarn from the yarn
feeder and keep the needles in working
position and the stitches
in the hooks of each needle.
Carefully pull your working yarn taut.
You'll see the current row
of stitches straighten.
Then you'll lift the
working yarn up and back.
This forces the row of stitches below to
pop up and over the fronts of the hooks.
You've removed one row.
Now be sure your stitches
don't slide behind the latches.
Make sure they stay in
the hooks of the needles.
Now repeat this in the opposite direction.
When that's finished,
you've got two rows removed.
The trick is to pull and
wiggle, pull and wiggle.
Remove each stitch carefully.
For the machines with gate pegs, take care
that the stitches don't pop up over the
gate peg and get caught.
Plus having weigh on your work will help.
Work slowly so each
stitch forms correctly.
Now, here's a tip.
Be careful and count the
number of rows you've removed.
Don't get carried away and lose track.
Instead of adjusting your row counter each
time, pull out a needle at the end of your
needle bed for each row you rip.
When you've removed all the rows needed,
change your row counter, return those
needles back to out of work position
and return to your knitting.
Fair Isle patterns can be
ripped in this fashion.
It just takes a little longer because
you'll be pulling two yarns instead of
one.
Garter stitch or any stitches that have
been turned can't be ripped as easily this
way.
Lace doesn't rip out very nicely either
because of the transferred stitches.
Usually slip and tuck patterns work
pretty well with this fast method.
Speed ripping on the chunky or the bulky
machines can be a little more difficult
because of the shape of the
sinker posts, but it can be done.
I recommend practicing speed ripping on
a swatch before you get into trouble on a
garment.
With a little practice, you'll be a pro.